[Musique]
quel a été le prix le plus élevé jamais
payé pour un thon rouge
plus de quatre millions de dollars cette
prise de 2 178 kg a été vendue aux
enchères au marché de poissons de tokyo
en 2019
lors des fêtes entourant le nouvel an
c'est près de 15000 dollars le kilo
si le thon rouge atteint parfois de
telle somme c'est dû à son importance
dans la culture japonaise et aussi à la
rareté de la ressource
mais de tels prix ne reflète pas se
payer aux pêcheurs à travers le monde et
s'applique seulement à des prises
particulièrement impressionnante
à certains moments de l'année pour
pallier la diminution des stocks
mondiaux on multiplie donc les efforts
pour développer l'aquaculture de ce
poisson qui peut atteindre plus de trois
mètres de longueur capturer des
juvéniles exempt dressées dans des cages
flottantes est une technique déjà connu
mais nîmes le renouvellement des
populations sauvages
c'est pourquoi on tente d'élever la
prestigieuse espèce de l'oeuf à l'adulte
mais faire pondre des thons en captivité
et a mené ce grand migrateur à maturité
dans des bassins demeure encore
aujourd'hui le saint graal de
l'aquaculture